[Music]
return to ccsd coming up on monday for
hundreds of thousands of students and
teachers it's a busy time of year and
while this new year promises a fresh
start for a lot uh some challenges of
course still linger for the district
christian casata sat down with the
superintendent today and he's a touching
on teacher retention concerns kristin
that's right doctor tara says staffing
is a big focus for the district but so
is retaining the teachers year after
year he says there are incentives to get
educators to stay and attract out the
state the out-of-state teachers as well
well right now
we have to do whatever we need to do to
get educators right and then it's our
job to not only onboard them but then
also to
retain them and keep them here so these
are things that we have to do long term
but yeah we you know partnering with our
with our bargaining unit with our unions
you know we raised the salary the
majority of the board really supported
and
voted for our teachers are over 50 000 a
year you know that was from 43 to 50
000. now even in the top end of the
scale we also raised that to retain our
educators regarding uh zone
uh school zones
how is that working out how is the
district keeping track on where students
go that's uh you know something that
it's it's tough right and and again
things that we're learning and that we
had to you know take an opportunity
coming back from covid um you know it
was not only efficiencies the big
question that i asked the first time is
why are we allowing uh students to zone
or go into on a zone variance to
overcrowded schools we're centralizing
it as uh with our board policy and you
know it's
hard you know the change is hard
but you know in the large scheme of
things we're working through a lot of
these challenges what's different this
year because i know that with covid
so many things changed we did learn a
lot seeing kids in school there's like
nothing else
as we look at right um you know i was
just commenting before we started you
know five years but i've opened school
seven times because we had to open up
school twice in one year right so so
that gives you some energy as you start
seeing kids
well dr jarrow said the pandemic tested
many things on how students learned and
many of those options are being
evaluated today now coming up at six
o'clock we asked dr jara about concerns
over monkey pox for the next school year
and what he hopes his legacy will be at
ccsd once he leaves christian casa is
live local now